please welcome to the stage director
Ryan
[Applause]
uncle Beto
then I
poor burger
[Applause]
Booya
Andy's gorgeous
[Applause]
whis to do and within you right
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
welcome it's nice to see you all here
last year we just got a little bit of a
glimpse and this year you're all here
stuffs been done I ran into Chadwick
after I think it was a civil war and I
said oh my god
Black Panther is like one of the most
amazing things I really hope there's a
Black Panther movie you go well who
knows and then a week later was
announced so what has it been like for
you you know going into this project and
you know been be you're being Black
Panther I'm sorry about that while bad
no yeah anything you couldn't see them
uh you know what it's amazing it's
amazing when we talked about this one
beginning you know I couldn't talk about
it and it was a big secret so it was
just good to be able to share bits and
pieces with everyone as it goes out and
it's beautiful to see how excited people
are about it have you seen the trailer
did you get a chance to the trailer the
Black Panther what are we going to learn
about the child on Black Panther and
what's going on with Lokhande well he's
uh he's returning from the events of
Civil War so you know he's lost his
father so he's just learning how to to
to deal with becoming a new ruler and
he's still mourning you know his
father's death so it's just it's a
transition period that gets interrupted
very quickly right and is he just kind
of struggling for trying to figure out
what kind of King he wants to be exactly
yeah I saw the trailer yeah a few times
maybe maybe several times yo man what's
this been like for you Ryan I mean we
were we were here last year and it was
still very new and very fresh and I know
this this comic in particular was really
really close to you and really important
so can you talk a little bit about your
history
with the comic and and how you brought
it onto the screen first I'll just like
to shout ready to be background holidays
and once every time I come back has
become more and more especially when my
first time always as I share with our
last year I was all the way in the back
like that for our back seat and being up
here now with you guys is the same and
and um and this this comic book is
coming book in particular to be a part
of bringing this to life and bringing
this to you guys it means everything to
me man I grew up as a you know as a
young black kid in the Bay Area and okay
I grew up loving comic books and it
didn't matter what what colors are
coming the comic book character was I
will follow x-men I'll follow spider-man
you know um but but I remember as I got
older you know I wanted to find a comic
book character who looked like I did and
I'm going into the comic book shop and I
asked if they had any you know in the
first the first one I take the comic
book owner took me over to see was Black
Panther you know so you know falling in
love with the character back then and
being able to to bring it to life with
this you know with this amazing studio
and this amazing filmmaker right here
Kevin fighting with these incredible
actors and to be here at Comic Con to
share with you guys is amazing man was
there anything particularly in the comic
that you felt was important to bring to
the screen anything in particular
yeah I thought that the best thing about
the comic book was was that the child
with somebody who got his power from
from the people around him and from his
history you know I mean history is
something that's incredibly important to
me and my family the people that I work
with most readily important to African
culture you know um so that's so that's
the really the cool thing I'm excited to
bring to bring about this excellent
this question is for latisha so what can
you say about Sheree is there anything
that you can share with Sheree is two
challahs younger sister and she is like
the technological like wizards of akanda
she designs all the new technology she's
she's a scientist and she was like a
dream role to play you know
inspirational
innovative just strong black woman and
then come on and not just a black poem
about a woman you know and it was it was
just beautiful to play that so I'm
excited for you guys gonna see for you
know sure he's gonna bring two for
Condor excellent yeah this is for Jenai
who I feel like you've had a lot of okay
because you you had so much weapons
drinking from walking dead but did this
feel like having even more intense
process so did you come in feeling like
oh yeah I know how to do all this
already no I did not be alone I do
whatever that was I did not feel that it
definitely was a new process and it was
awesome like we would all be in the room
together like working all like five
everybody would be up in there and we'd
be in different corners or together
doing drills learning new stuff new
lines I mean she works with a whole
different weapon and there are some
overlaps but not a lot like it was
actually a whole new process which was
awesome because it was about what I love
about her is that it's all connected to
the fact that this woman is driven by a
love for her nation for her people
and the beauty of Wakanda is that it is
this place that is the most successful
the most advanced nation on earth and on
the continent whoa stop it get me
excited right now I just love that about
the movie I love that about the story
and so the fact that she is really
protecting that and that's what drives
her weaponry that's what drives her what
she does as as a warrior it's all driven
by love of her people and what her
forefathers and foremothers put in place
excellent
Michael what can you say about Eric how
does he fit into everything oh man I
feel like Eric has his own point of view
in opinions on Wakanda and how it should
be ruled and he he Oh careful now killer
ah he tries to UM he has his eyes on the
throne he has his eyes on the throne so
I think he's trying to do whatever it
takes to kind of to to get into you know
to Wakanda to make that a reality
excellent and then Forest Whitaker it's
an honor to have him here can you talk a
little bit about jury and then being III
guess sort of a mentor maybe to chala
can you talk a little bit about his role
yeah yeah it's great to be here with
everybody I'm still excited but first
Comic Con yeah um yeah he he's been
working as a super spiritual leader and
he was very close friends with his
father as a result he's started to has
been working with him since he was a
little child
this was young and trying to give him
the advice that would hopefully mold him
in some way I guess into being King and
following in that lineage of Kings and
advises the Kings he has a relationship
with a big job excellent just on a
personal note I want to say to Daniel
Kelly that I think get out with a
game-changing George
it's such a brilliant job in redefining
the genre and making something original
and making something beautiful and it
was it was an incredible movie and I
want to congratulate you I'm sure you've
been hearing that a lot here but so what
can you say about what hobby um this is
so surreal I can say about what copy I
could say is to Charlie Szold his friend
they were like childhood friends and
he's part of the leader of the border
tribe and he's head of security so
anything that comes in and out so he
sees the side of what's coming into what
kind of what's trying to come in at
Organa what's what and he stops it
he's a very hidden figure nice was this
it was it was this was it fun when
you're doing this kind of movie because
you get to do it and it feels like it's
such a to be in this kind of a film feel
so energetic and incredible but it's an
incredible amount of work I mean this
film feels so physical it is it is that
part of a challenge is that challenging
to when you're acting around like
everything that's so physical it is wild
yeah there was a day our continent a
continent
it was younger this stuff happen yeah it
looks like and I say yeah we really
deserve the Sun training then everyone
was had their own different fighting
styles and it was fun and it was a drama
that was like that was drumming while
people who buy in and it was like
watching on Good Morning Glory
and then the pizza it's also an honor to
have you here
thank you I know thank you
I'll be back what can you say how's the
experience been well I will say first of
all thank you so much for the comic-con
love I saw someone dressed as Eric two
longer yesterday and I was dope so thank
you thank you whoever that was already
already they have mass they made their
own masks and it was really incredible
that's so yeah so what can you say what
can you say about the key is there
anything you can share well I can say
that Nakia is a spy and she goes
undercover to the rest of the world and
report a report back to what Conda about
the goings on so what Conda is this
isolated nation and it keeps to itself
and in order to keep safe they have to
send people like Nakia out they're known
as war dogs to let we keep what Conda on
top of things
you know what continent needs to know
what's going on around the world the
world does not need to know what's going
on in Wakanda excellent
and you circus all the way down at the
end if you listen
[Applause]
he's it he's a bit of a poacher what is
he what is he up to what is he up to
it's like well two things I get to wear
pants in this movie and secondly I get
an arm back you know because I ended up
on the last movie losing my arm so I get
my arm back which is pretty cool and of
course you know Ulysses is he's a
wheeler delays he's a lone wolf but he
can pick up the phone to any government
and compromise them and you know so
you'd fit in pretty well in today's
society really it's it was really
amazing working on this set because I
think Ryan Coogler is just the most
incredible director in human being who
has just created this wonderful
beautiful life on set where where
everyone was able to literally operate
at their maximum use so he's such a
liberating director to work with it
allows you to explore and collaborate
and and I just had the most brilliant
wonderful time working with all these
guys amazing excellent oh did you come
out to the line oh nice you know how to
do it Andy Serkis
Winston is this your first comic-con yes
this is definitely my first welcome
welcome
this is this is amazing and I've only
seen this online and on TV and the love
and reception is just something that is
breathtaking so thank you excellent
so you we've seen a little glimpse of
you in the trailer actually lifting
another human being
ah so what can you say what can you tell
everyone here about Baku what can you
say
well um Baku is this a big strong
ferocious majestic you know charismatic
beloved leader a leader of the Javari
tribe the best tribe in Wakanda all
right no no no this is my time so the
best tribe in Wakanda
but yeah so he what really drew me and I
found really hot about this role was
just how human and the depth that was in
this character because he's really loyal
to his people and you know deeply
faith-driven and all these wonderful
things that made him have a lot of range
so yeah he's a really cool guy
really cool character
you